another thing that's important for play
mastery and especially for opening you
up to really moving your body is the
idea of jiggies I the idea of jig is for
me came right out of tai chi cousin Tai
Chi you don't move your arm you move
your body and your arms just reflect how
your bodies are moving sorry my type you
kept my Tai Chi teacher kept Rome yet
it's not this it's this your hand might
not move away from your sternum it makes
a circle but it's not in relation to
your body your body is moving so as soon
as I picked up poi the same thing seems
very natural go ahead you'll be famous
so once you get to play crossing you're
crossing side to side what you can do is
you know grab your hand with your other
hand pull them into your ribs and slowly
learn how that movement can come out of
your body not your arms because if you
look at my hands my hands aren't moving
at all relative to my body it's like I'm
in a straitjacket my hands are just on
my sternum but my body's pivoting and
that's controlling the poi so if you can
learn to do this forwards and backwards
that's really gonna affect on a very
fundamental level how and it's really
important the term jiggies comes from
Iraqi who's been around in the play
world for a long time offered a lot of
wisdom into the poi world when I was in
this I just turned my body and the point
comes with me just play with that and
anything you're doing this play just
play with how the rocking of your body
can control the point set of your arm
know wherever the players can be at your
hip and it just be swinging your hips
will pull the play around but you
reaching out here it's just that swaying
those two work for you and what that's
gonna do is that's going to make the
when you play it's gonna come as an
expression of your entire movement
instead of just an expression of
standing there with your arms which
feels good and it looks nice and it's a
lot of fun so you know I'll talk more
about that in the coming weeks but just
make sure in the beginning you're really
playing with that you should not move
from here move from your hips or your
legs relax breathe jiggy you got it